عشرات القتلى نتيجه العواصف التي تضرب شرق
امريكا حمله واسعه في السودان لمحاربه
انتشار مخدر الشيطان اكتشاف معدنين في
الصومال لا مثيل لهما على الارض هذه
الاخبار وغيرها منقولها لكم من قناه
العربيه اهلا بكم
فيما تتواصلوا العصر الثلجيه القاسيه بضرب
مناطق شرق الولايات المتحده الامريكيه
اعلنت سلطات عن تسجيل احدى وثلاثين وفاء
مرتبطه بهذه العواصف تقارير تحدث ايضا عن
ازمه متفاقمه في مدينه
الطوارئ من الوصول الى المناطق شديده
التضرر في ما وصف مسؤولون الوضع في
المدينه بانه خطير وغير مسبوق خصوصا مع
العثور على زوجته داخل سيارات وتحت اكوام
الثلوج بينما يكافح رجال الانقاذ للبحث عن
اولئك الذين يحتاجون الى مساعده
بعد ما شهدت الفتره الاخيره تفشيا لافتا
للمخدرات بانواعها في السودان اطلق ناشطون
هاشتاج الحق ولدك لمحاربه تفشي هذه الافه
بصوره عامه ومخدر الايس كريستال الفتاك
المعروف بمخدر الشيطان على وجه الخصوص
تقارير صحفيه كشفت عن تورط مافيا دوليه
ذات اذرع محليه في تهريب المخدرات الى
الاراضي السودانيه مشيره الى ان هذه
التجاره لم تعد تقتصر على الحشيش او
البانجو اذا توسعت انشطتها الاجراميه
لتهريب الهيروين فيما افادت معلومات بان
الشرطه تضبط بشكل شبه يوميا شحنات مخدرات
في العاصمه او الولايات الاخرى
وافقت شركه متى العملاقه للملكه لمنصه
فيسبوك على الدفع مبلغ ضخم لانهاء دعوه
قضائيه اطلقت في عام 2018 للمطالبه
بتعويضات من الشركه المتهمه بالسماح
لاطراف الثالثه للوصول الى البيانات محام
الدفاع قالوا في وثيقه قضائيه تم رفعها
الى محكمه سان فرانسيسكو ان المبلغ قالوا
ان المبلغ المقدره بسبع مئه وخمسه وعشرين
مليون دولار والذي اقترحته الاتفاقيه يعد
اعلى مبلغ يتم التوصل اليه في دعوى جماعيه
بشان البيانات الخاصه وتم دفعه من قبل
فيسبوك لانهاء هذا النوع من الدعوه
والقضائيه
في اكتشاف يعد الاول من نوعها افادت شبكه
سي ان ان الامريكيه بان علماء كنديين
عثروا على معدنين لا مثيل لهما على كوكب
الارض في النيزك سقط على الصومال خلال عام
2020 بيانو صحفي لجامعه البرتغال الكنديه
كشف ان النيزك وهو تاسع اكبر نيزك وجد على
الاطلاق مشيرا الى ان وزنه يبلغ نحو 15
طنا وتم العثور عليها قرب بلده العلي في
الصومال واضاف البيان ان المعدنين لم يتم
التعرف عليهما بواسطه المجهر ليتبين لاحقا
انهما معدنا جديدان وهما عباره عن فوسفات
من الحديد
وفي خبرينا الاخير اصيب 51 شخصا بالتسمم
بعد انحراف قطار ينقل الامونيا في مدينه
بيروت جنوب شرق صربيا وتسرب الغاز السام
من عرباته وزاره الداخليه اوضح حتى في
بيان ان القطار القادم من بلغاريا خرج عن
مساره ما ادى الى تسرب الامونيا وانتشار
كميه كبيره من الغاز في الهواء فيما اعلنت
السلطات المحليه حاله الطوارئ في الجزء
المتضرر من المدينه التي يبلغ عدد سكانها
60 الف نسمه مطالبه السكان